[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will discuss and
showcase the 10 underwater creatures
from Pandora according to size from the
tiny to the Titans so let's get to it
number 10 the nicktoid this one meter or
3.3 feet long piranha-like monster
inhabits Pandora's lakes and murky
lowland drainages it has a robot's armor
making it tougher than other fishes it
has two enormous projecting red eyes on
its head that can see for great
distances underwater in low light it
also has a disturbingly lifelike
face-like form of a humanoid formed by
Falls at the top of the skull to scare
off Predators the teeth in its mouth are
also triangular and blade-like in shape
number nine the Sagittarius this is a
cephalopod-like creature around 1.2
meters or 4 feet long and are found in
Pandora's lakes and seas and they have a
strong shell that can retract completely
for safety and 14 muscular tentacles 10
tentacles protrude from the underside of
the body largely for mobility and four
near the mouth primarily for
pre-attraction and eating despite its
watery nature its prey consists of
little winged species that fly in the
air and they kill their prey by using
water jets
number eight the Gill mantle this Gill
mantle which is a two to three meters or
6.5 to 10 feet long underwater species
is an invertebrate creature that lives
in Pandora's oceans the semi-transparent
Gill metal is a valued symbiote since
its permits the navi to spend more time
underwater so when a navi links with it
the Gill mantle acts as a biological
diving suit supplying oxygen to the
linked Navi via their neurological
connection the Gill mantle has the look
and fluid motions of a tearing jellyfish
and when connected to a navi it glows
Crimson in color
number seven the pincer fish the pincer
fish is a Pandora aquatic species it has
a bright blue body and each of its jaws
has a projecting horn that forms a
pincer shape it has one huge fin that
extends from its backside and wraps
around its body and it is brightly
marked the animal is not harmful to the
navi and are found in both oceans and
large lakes and they can grow to around
three to four meters or 10 to 13 feet
long
number six the third repeat a Pandora
reptile that appears like a hybrid
between a turtle a platypus and a
starfish it is seen swimming slowly
across freshwater lakes and rivers but
it also has adapted to Salty seas
torpedes are armored with numerous fins
and also a fully developed centipede is
16 to 20 feet or 5 to 6 meters long from
head to tail and 13 feet of 4 meters
tall with its large dorsal fin and long
tail the terpene is agile underwater
number five the ilu the ilu is a giant
plesiosaur like Marine creature that are
the oceanic metakolina's glands dire
horse also performing a biological role
comparable to that of a Terran dolphin
in the wild slick and graceful aquatic
reptiles with a long neck six flippers
and rather like tail similar to Earth's
extinct pleasure saw species it also has
four eyes with two Q antenna like neural
whips that protrude from its temples
they are on average 7 meters or 23 feet
long but sometimes can grow to be very
large around twice the size
number four the skim Wing this is a
large predatory marine animal in Pandora
yet they are also a species that are
domesticated by the metcalina navi the
skim Wing at around 14.6 meters or 48
feet long is huge and huge enough to
carry a fully grown Navi on its back it
has a gray skin an orange with a dark
patterns on its enormous fins which
partially lift it out of the water like
a Terran flying fish with its powerful
tail the skim Wing can travel up to 50
knots or 58 miles per hour or 92
kilometers per hour
number three the nalissa the nalissa is
a sixth Guild monster that dwells in
Pandora's oceans Coastal Waters and may
be seen springing out of the sea it is a
hyper carnivorous animal that may grow
to be around 40 meters or 131 feet long
similar to Earth's Dunkleosteus or
sharks massive and armored with no
dorsal fin and two set of flippers
fashioned like a humpback whale it also
has a lengthy tail culminating in Jagged
and flaring flukes it has a large but
relatively short set of jaws with salt
length teeth
number two the accula the akula is a
Pandora ocean animal similar to the
sharks of Earth's waters as shown in
Avatar too it is the naluza's aggressive
and secretive relative the metcalina
clan regards the akula as culturally
significant tonawari wears a necklace
made of regular teeth and the serrated
edges of the Clans blades are styled at
the creature's teeth as well it has
three Jaws that split outwards in three
ways when hunting it is also around 40
meters or 131 feet long
and number one the Tolkien these are
seen in Long sequences in avatar The
Wave water tokens are extremely clever
beings they are definitely smarter than
humans as well as more spiritual and
emotional however like Wales this
intelligence can only be displayed in
their own unique way the Tolkien is
allegedly Pandora's biggest fauna
reaching lengths of up to 300 feet or
91.4 meters long when fully grown
despite their size they are agile enough
to burst out of the water and they live
in ports of families that travel around
the world's oceans and sometimes
frequent the metcalina Clans forming
bonds like sisterhoods so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video on the
12 underwater creatures from Pandora so
to hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash the Bell
icon for regular updates on new videos
here on this channel till the next one
take care fam